hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the things in the
night I'm about to plug into this Curt
chunk okay that wasn't as xcos
existentially important as I thought it
might have been either way I got a knife
which is one of three items that I need
to do to the victim and the father in
them the other guy you know death row I
think his name is yeah
oh the demon that's right the demon the
demon the victim and the father I have a
blade of the rectum dramatic music hello
hand holding a key well I wonder ding
dings click click who back here I like
back here
ahh ahh and here's where that stuff is
and this incredibly awesome contraption
that he's got going on right here you
know what I don't understand
I mean the frame rates are pretty ok in
here and there's so much more stuff but
in that other area was like I'm not sure
why that was but either way I'm not
complaining about the lag very much I
think is it
oh okay here yeah a cha what them hot
jars
oh yeah the hand do doink yeah okay well
whatever then I guess I need the other
things to get anything to happen all
right
so to the house the old house here's a
brick Oh Brandon Brandon oh and there
another songwriter lyrics this old house
lots of blood gallons of blood there an
easter egg I'm gonna find it
I'm gonna find it I'm gonna find the
secrets Oh invisible wall eh maybe on
the other side and I'm gonna getcha
okay yeah oh sorry I gotta be real
spurring with that voice because you
know it's kind of moronic
nope invisible walls doesn't look like
there's any secrets around oh well
toodaloo yeah it's pretty barren yep no
bouquet alright moving forward man
it's interesting to think of how close
together this map is and how I haven't
really traveled very far but I feel like
I've been walking for a long time
oh hi there how's it going buddy have a
drink you need to learn to drink proper
okay anyway uh uh finally I've actually
got a stockpile of oil it's so weird and
there it goes
Finn it's me Sara
if you have to go in there just remember
to be careful this isn't a safe place oh
this is a girl this isn't a safe place
how many have died in here this is all I
can do for now I'll give you some oil to
light your way and some painkillers as
well so I'm Sara it's the best girl I do
I have to deeper voice to do a good
girls voice don't judge me I can hear
you out there I'm listening I'm right
here all right so anyway
any minute now it's gonna load up
and everyone let's be set a spider on
that guy holy crap huh if Sarah is in
here somehow how is she not dead how am
I not dead hey buddy
scuse me I need this chair please can I
borrow a chair thank you
give you something culture ah nicely
done I think I've seen a safe like that
in another custom story not one nearly
as good as this I need to read it all I
see in there ah gotcha I need to
reiterate that this is by far the best
custom story that I've ever played and
I'm not just saying that because you
know the author the story is writing in
the comments and I've been talking to
him about it but legitimately this is by
far and I think you all will agree this
is the best custom story I've ever seen
I mean those of you out here who are
playing along with me I know I know some
of you play whatever ones I do but I
think you'll agree this is by far the
best
I can't wait to see you I'm not even
done with this on I can't wait to see
what else this guy makes up oh hello oh
there's nothing here
girl why doesn't anyone put any this is
the worst ever no one puts anything at
the bottom of the stairs well actually I
think in a stairs this boy I think you
did put some stuff up there so under
there so I'll forgive them just as flu
footprints hmm someone who's playing
hopscotch one two one two one two okay
what's down here ah it balderdash
everything needs a key when they stare
don't work too well I need to go thank
you very much need to be very
conservative about my use of oil
mood shifted it suddenly got quite a bit
more creepy in here but I am a rock I
will persevere first
I'm trying to learn to be very good
about my use of of my lantern you know
putting it away quite often and only
bringing it out when I need to actually
check to see if something's there
because that's smart and I'm if I'm one
thing it's more all this smartness juice
up in my brain Kairo takers note this is
hornier that's for reading this not turn
back now this place is nothing but evil
and full of death some ass remember this
castle has gone mad and he's killing all
of the servants and even his own kids
and wife can't escape from him so please
come back now she's been warned but you
also said that I couldn't escape because
I'm his kid or something like that
I don't know fade away
okay so I was if I was smart I would run
out screaming to the front door but I
don't know why I'm not just bothering
don't leave it's not like something's
threatened to follow me Wow it's a
masters corner of course it'd be loved
sleeping quarter and study loved nice of
fact you can mind a creepy or even some
rain that's cool
Oh what ah very atmospheric I like it
Wow is it's in a closet it's a room I
don't have a key
well well balderdash this is the only
way what did I miss something in that
other room that I could go in probably
all right go back down all the way
Masters quarter I'll be back for you for
sure do they must be up right here right
off the bat I find something that I
missed
cuz I managed it smash ok so there's got
to be something here
bookshelf maybe somewhere in plain sight
like on the ground in the middle table
chair a bowl grandfather clock painting
can be ripped off the wall maybe books
lock look there were a lot of paintings
on the way up I should probably check
them okay I do not see anything in here
oh wow oh yeah oh yeah
second floor key oh yeah I'm depressed
Oh Wester ever wash well I'm so great
I'll feed my ego guys don't stop tell me
how great I am
no took that came for behind that door
oh that's right run away
she's walking awfully strange
well that's not much light at all like
that no don't look at it
yeah I'm being much much better about my
oil
then this window looks weak and cracked
it should break easily with ah sure am I
gonna do about these freaking iron bars
I must find a way to raise them about
whatever this is
nevermind I'm an idiot ah here eh
looks like a room of Secrets
nothing there's been less and less in
those things as of late switches co
hooks Galloway chair you're such a dick
[Music]
okay oh I already opened see why oh man
oh that was good I mean it was joke
scare but still it was like so well it's
good because I'd already opened it
didn't big oh okay
my master has locked down the third
floor he said no one is to go in there
due to the sickness that the servants
have forgotten and that we have to throw
the debt down in the basement the last
person I know and remember the hand the
key to the third floor was robbed but
he's now dead dead in the basement
either way no one is going to go in the
third floor at all master doors unmarked
oh that's cruel joke cruel cruel joke oh
okay alright I'm fine I'm fine
okay stories jam there's no way a key
will work and the wood is too strong for
a hammer too strong for a chair oh yeah
boom blingy earth too strong for me
impossible okay get open get your face
open I've fourths chairs through less
conspicuous orifices get in there got in
there okay okay anyway
oh wait no I gotta know if there's no
way a key will work or maybe that's just
for her psychology it was not why do I
have this mixture for an asset oh yeah
that's way back when that's for the
thing I accidentally skipped okay moving
on I'm better now I'm better I'm
actually almost out of time so uh thank
you all so much for watching all I think
like what cam got moved thank you all so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part
bye-bye